[Música]
si repentinamente los insectos
aumentaran mucho en tamaño y decidieran
declararnos la Guerra sin duda los
humanos perderíamos seríamos aniquilados
por su superioridad numérica se estima
que hay 10 trillones de insectos en el
planeta eso es un uno seguido por 19
ceros En comparación con nuestra
población de unos siete mil millones hay
mil millones de estos invertebrados por
cada humano
las cifras a nivel de especies son
impresionantes también existen más de
60.000 especies de vertebrados en el
planeta pero se conoce un millón de
especies de insectos y muchas otras que
no han sido catalogadas
de hecho estas criaturas son un 75% de
todos los animales del planeta
Cuál es el secreto de su éxito el número
elevado de insectos se debe a muchas
cosas que juntas los hacen las criaturas
más adaptables y resistentes en
particular su impresionante capacidad de
reproducción
muchas especies tienen una gran
descendencia la mayoría morirá pero una
cantidad más que suficiente sobrevivirá
para reproducirse las crías maduran muy
deprisa por lo que el ciclo reproductivo
se reanuda rápidamente y tiene lugar
varias veces cada poco tiempo
estas cifras significan que como clase
la diversidad genética de los insectos
es enorme la riqueza de la información
genética de estas especies les
proporciona lo necesario para adaptarse
y prosperar en muchos entornos en todo
el planeta
Incluso en los más extremos los
escarabajos de la corteza pueden vivir a
menos 40 grados Celsius las hormigas del
desierto del Sahara pueden soportar
temperaturas de 70 grados celsius y
algunos abejorros pueden sobrevivir a
5.500 metros sobre el nivel del mar
los exoesqueletos de insectos también
hacen de armadura corporal que los
protegen del mundo exterior y les
permiten sobrevivir en hábitats donde
otras criaturas no resisten incluso su
tamaño pequeño que puede parecer una
desventaja es algo que usan a su favor
la mayoría de las especies son tan
diminutas que millones de insectos
pueden compartir un espacio pequeño y
disponer de todos los recursos
existentes pueden ocupar varios cientos
de nichos en todos los ecosistemas
algunos insectos se alimentan de Raíces
tallos hojas semillas polen y néctar de
plantas específicas otros como las
Avispas capturan insectos vivos y
paralizan a sus víctimas para depositar
huevos dentro de estas
cuando sus larvas nacen se alimentan de
las víctimas
los mosquitos y las moscas que pican se
alimentan de sangre y aprovechan este
recurso inusual para asegurar su
supervivencia muchos otros insectos
anidan en heces las moscas ponen sus
huevos allí y algunos escarabajos
Incluso hacen grandes bolas de estiércol
que luego comen y usan para sus huevos
y luego está el gran poder de la
metamorfosis este rasgo no solo
transforma a los insectos sino que les
ayuda a optimizar los recursos
disponibles en un ecosistema por ejemplo
las mariposas la oruga durante su etapa
larval devora voraz y rápidamente el
follaje lo que le ayuda a crecer y tejer
capullos pero al transformarse en
mariposa se alimenta de néctar de flores
la metamorfosis significa que las larvas
y los adultos de la misma especie nunca
competirán por el mismo recurso y por
eso se benefician del mismo Nicho
ecológico sin limitar su propio éxito
este proceso es tan eficaz que el 86% de
las especies de insectos sufren
metamorfosis completa
Nosotros somos grandes y ellos pequeños
por eso es fácil olvidar que hay
millones de estos bichos a nuestro
alrededor todo el tiempo
pero examine cualquier Rincón Y
seguramente los verá allí su cantidad es
muy elevada y su éxito inigualable tal
vez deberíamos aceptar que son los
insectos no nosotros los verdaderos amos
del planeta
Entonces si los insectos son las
especies más abundantes del planeta Por
qué no somos más los que los comemos
comer insectos podría ayudar a las
personas a conseguir una mejor seguridad
alimentaria profundice en las
posibilidades con este video